thank you thank thank you thank you all
right that's
enough when it comes to Twitter he's no
quitter as anyone to the right of Chay
Gua knows Twitter prior to Elon Musk had
become the bullhorn of the woke
disseminating and amplifying MOB driven
antipathy toward anyone who didn't
genuflect before the alter of divisive
identity Politics as most people could
see they used to censor conservatives a
lot true on Twitter the right were less
popular than the veggie tray in lizzo's
Green
Room damn they even threw the hilarious
Babylon be off the site The Babylon be a
satirical Outlet did the Free Speech
mavens come to its defense nope they saw
the bee as an enemy because it rightly
made fun of them and so if you tweeted
something that went against the
prevailing liberal left opinion you were
banned like Bill Hammer from a nude
beach can't say they blame him
anyway X formerly known as Twitter
claimed that they didn't censor anybody
because that's what hardcore leftists do
they stifled dissent and then they lie
about it and they would have got away
with it too if it wasn't for that
meddling billionaire Elon Musk paid 44
billion bucks and turned Twitter into X
and explained why he did it on Joe Rogan
the de of which Twitter was simply um an
arm of the government was not well
understood by the public a state
publication is the way to think of
Twitter it it's a state publication
Republicans were suppressed at 10 times
the rate of Democrats
interesting but what was what was what
was it that ultimately led him to make
the decision to do it was he worried
that it was having a corrosive effect on
civilization what was it ultimately that
led you to make the decision to do it I
was worried about that that it was
having a corrosive effect on
civilization if you've walked around
downtown San Francisco right near the X
FKA Twitter headquarters it's a zombie
apocalypse now you have to say well what
philosophy led to that outcome and that
philosophy was being piped to Earth a
philosopy that would be ordinarily quite
Niche and geographically constrained so
the that sort of the fallout area would
be
limited first of
all I love what Rogan has done with his
hair he looks like the one woman left
after last call at your local
Benin
that's not an insult but musk is right
he calls old Twitter an information
technology weapon to propagate a mind
virus to the rest of the earth and that
walking around San Fran shows you the
results of that mind virus the end of
civilization because if you couldn't
walk to work without stepping in a pile
of human and dirty drug needles of
course you'd want to share that Utopia
with the rest of the world and in order
for that mind virus to propagate you
must suppress opposing viewpoints you
need to silence the the people who
recognize how harmful your policies are
censorship isn't a byproduct of leftism
it is leftism because if people can hear
opposing ideas they might think you know
digging ditches in this goog isn't as
fun as they said it would be censorship
and leftism you can't have one without
the other sort of like Brian kilme in
the Men's
Warehouse yeah it's the only time they
didn't like the way they
looked musk also said George Soros is
trying try to erode the fabric of
civilization if that sounds like
hyperbole then you haven't been to a
city lately and it begs for the
comparison between these two
billionaires Soros used his vast Fortune
to Target local races because he knew
that's where his money could do the most
damage not in presidential races the
result an end to bail a rise in
recidivist violent crime and a
decriminalization of everything from
larsy to carjacking turning once's great
cities into open air petting zoos for
junkies thugs and Maniacs meanwhile what
it must do protect your freedom of
expression as opposed to limiting your
freedom from crime she musk understood
how a small number of people could
commandeer and enforce an idea ideology
on a nation he knew history you don't
need a majority to create tyranny just a
minority living in a five square mile
Block in Northern California and now
what now what they try to do to Twitter
is what Biden wanted to do wants to do
now with AI get the same people in
charge to get the same horrible outcomes
and if all that's too heavy for you musk
reportedly plans to add a fully-fledged
dating component to the app next year
talk about hooking up with your
ex
no but do we really need another dating
app frankly I missed the days of getting
to know someone the oldfashioned way you
know when you stood outside their
bedroom window for hours while they
slept but the idea is all about making X
into an everything app as he looks for
ways to inject new cash flow into the
company because it's now worth almost
65% less than when he bought it so was
he stupid for doing this no he was Brave
this might be the biggest Financial
sacrifice anyone ever did on behalf of a
country but then again he is worth 225
billion so to him 44 billion is like a
haircut for Jesse Waters
so no wonder he lets Joe Rogan shoot an
arrow into the side of his brand new
Cyber
[Applause]
truck this blew the BW the arrow
apart flatten the tip of the arrow this
is going to be my next
car cuz you never know the next time
you'll be chasing faced by Liz
Warren that was a setup as for must
comments on the evils of leftism the
only people scoffing at him are leftists
the ones who benefited from Twitter
censorship namely mainstream journalists
a year ago they predicted the company
would collapse and they were licking
their lips like Jeffrey Epstein at
Spring break and said the only thing
that's tanked is the media's ratings
their numbers are falling faster than
Joe Biden on a
treadmill maybe not all of elon's moves
so far have been
but he's doing it for the right reasons
musk believes in free speech and if you
don't believe it just insult him he
won't block you but he will mock you and
he certainly won't send the feds after
you let's welcome tonight's guest he's
the inspiration behind the American
Indian term pale face Fox News
contributor Tom
shaloo she talks about hoops and ticks
off terrorist groups host of The Hoop
chat Emily
Austin
to get on her good side just throw her a
handful of bird seed New York Times
bestselling author and Fox News
contributor
ctim and finally his knuckle sandwich
can feed a family of five New York Times
bestselling author comedian and former
mwa world champion
[Applause]
Tyrus Tom it's kind of interesting that
this is what he would choose to spend
his money on what do you think of it I
love Elon Musk I mean I love the guy
he's uh he he he's like a he has every
right to be an evil billionaire but he's
just not being one it's really amazing
and he's so open he spent three hours
with Joe Rogan he'll go anywhere he
smokes cigars talks about anything
billionaires are very guarded they won't
give a three-minute interview I'm more
guarded than Elon Musk and I'm only a
thousand
a you know what is he's like Bruce Wayne
yes but he doesn't need the costume no
but he's having a ball and I love it and
uh I wish he didn't change the name of
Twitter but he makes mistakes like
Twitter was such a good name for the
company then he changed it to X I like
Twitter because I like the way he says
it Twitter Twitter yeah I bought Twitter
I bought Twitter for $44
million um the I just think he's an
interesting guy and it's a perfect
contrast between him and George Soros
who I mean you never see him he just
hides like the evil villain that he is
yes yeah um but uh you know and the
other thing just you notice that he's
referring to earth like he said was
sending messages to earth like he's
already like on Mars he already looks at
Earth as just another place for him you
know and you know what he's right when
you see how the world is going ominous
Point Emily how have you been thinking
about the Twitter dating app at all I I
would be I wouldn't okay I wouldn't join
it because I would rather wait outside
somebody's window at night I think it's
more like personal but I would be really
happy because it would primarily be
conserv aives cuz the left wants to
boycott X and I don't think it's a bad
thing for conservatives to start
procreating maybe we can like have four
or five six children build little
conservative armies start to outnumber
the left a little bit because you know
they're not going to be on the app so I
would be really elated if he can do that
and conservatives could just you know
like genetically have smarter kids and
then maybe suros wouldn't want to um
destroy civilization but if he was smart
you'd be friends with Elon you'd get on
one of his rockets and you have like
that f you money you can move to Mars
you can like develop it so if I were him
that's what I would do yeah I wish I had
a billionaire best
friend appliations open yes it'd be
amazing CAD don't you wish you had a
thousand air best
friend I
do um what do you make of uh let's say
let's say Twitter's progress now so he's
losing a lot of money he's losing
advertising but it's definitely and
there's a lot of misinformation on it
let's be honest but it's actually feels
like a good
thing yeah the dating thing I don't know
I mean you kind of already can do that
yeah I mean anything anything is a
dating app if you're creepy enough that
is true like door Dash customer service
like my food wasn't cold but I
am in bed at night come
over I wonder if that would work
probably would it probably would yeah
anything can be a dating app so I don't
even know like what would that mean the
the dating app on I think he's just kind
of trying stuff seeing what'll work
seeing what won't work you can also
already probably find someone to get you
pregnant on Twitter if that's what
you're looking for people offer me all
the time and I'm not
asking that's so true all right Tyrus
what what are you looking at no I'm just
just I'm listening to everything please
do not make that joke and call door
Dash no I'm going to but when they
be like wrong yeah cuz you staring at
your phone going he's here he's coming I
was joking I was joking I was joking um
I I've you know there's certain times in
life where you like you you see somebody
enough and you decide like hey I think I
want to be friends with this guy I think
I want to be friends with Elon because I
think I need to be one of the guys that
texts him at 2: in the morning like yo
Buy
Panama do it ask you know like I think
he's getting to the point now where he's
starting to like have so much fun being
the the the hated cool guy he's now
wearing weird his outfits are getting
weirder you know he's got an ascot and
he's the cigar and he changes his accent
from time to time he's having fun and
you know he's talks about Earth because
he's already bought Mars yeah you know
so and I'm you know I just want to be
able to text him like you know you need
to buy an Antarctica and let's see if we
can turn into a rainforest well you know
what the perfect example is he bought
Twitter because he was mad that they
banned Babylon that's why I want to be
friends with him yes like to be at a
point to when you don't like something
like I'm watching
CNN and somebody pisses me off on there
I just call the accountant and be like
yo buy all the stocks on CNN yeah buy it
all do we have it cool uh tells stelter
he has to wear a clown suit every night
on see an in fired like that's the stuff
I would I would do and I feel like Elon
would be the guy to call me like yo did
you just make him wear a clown suit
watch this I'm buying ABC wait till you
see soap offers this week no like I just
feel like that's kind of cool have cool
trips the moon would be I would be so
petty like if there were a Salesman or
somebody that upset me I would buy the
company so I could fire that person
after you do the correction yes after
you make them feel like it's going to be
okay then you go and then you bring them
in crush their soul hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else